there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dreamed them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one he'll lose
that one too
arrakis is a death trap this is an
extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
[Music]
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
my lord duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go
[Music]
oh man
you